[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you foreign
thank you
[Music]
jeez guys already 65 people in that chat
you guys really want to hear about this
star Phil release day don't you
I hear I hear you guys man I wanted to
talk about the star for release it just
as much as you want to hear about it I
hear it I hear you guys man
waiting for dirt to pull up he'll be
here any minute
salomo you want in this
you want to talk about it
dirt's not here yet
he's already communicated with me so I
know he's coming he's just not here at
the moment
thank you
foreign
guys I just woke up I spent like half
the night working on Pax East stuff
you guys got to see a little bit of the
back end stuff
oh it's kind of cold in here
oh there's
dirt
what's up dirt oh what's up man how you
doing
hold up
all right speak again
what's up brother how you doing what's
going on dirt
do I sound okay
you sound wonderful
all right
I'm so like
lost currently
all right
we already got 117 people in there Dirk
there's probably a bunch of ponies
waiting to see what we gonna say
we're already live too oh
yes uh we we here man you guys have to
apologize if I'm a little slow uh uh
today has just been a a really long day
I spent like half the night working on
Pax e stuff
and uh you know I got everything going
man got everything going so appreciate
apologize for last week I woke up
I decided because Dirk was uh busy with
uh real life stuff and I went to go to
the gym dirt because I at 10 are just
doing it by myself and then it was like
6 30 I'm like oh
so kind of worked out for you yeah yeah
so you know I had to I couldn't I
couldn't get off early last week
actually I had to work all the way to
eight o'clock last week bro
but I'm here this week though
yeah we
we we we go and stuff man we go and
stuff someone said in dirt We Trust
pyd what up bro
but appreciate if you guys coming out to
the attic show we talked about the past
present and future of gaming I'm your
host Lord addicts I have my co-host with
me Dirk griggity what's going on Dirk
what's up man how you doing buddy we
have a very
a very a lot of stuff to talk about man
yeah okay
I want to make sure that I haven't
missed things so what what's going on
well the big story of the day is
Starfield release date
yeah I saw that yeah that's the big
story of the day and can I do want to
point out just a little bit
um I called it I said September remember
yeah yeah you did you did I said
September because I said
uh hellblade would be November
hmm
um you know
it is what it is but you know we're got
what we'll talk about that here in a
momentarily you know the first thing I
want to talk about dirt I don't know if
if you
if you've played but I'm kind of curious
is uh wulong uh and the reason I want to
talk about wulong is because I honestly
think that
it's one of those examples that shows
well let me get the super chat from uh
slow-mo two dollar subscribe from Sloan
Watch Sony launch Spider-Man 2 in
September 2.
okay look you know what
slovo I hate you okay I guess we're
going to derail a little bit already
we're going to deraw a little bit uh we
let me make a new thing can star filled
compete
with
Spider-Man
look solo I had every intentions on
talking about wulong but now you've
completely derailed the podcast so
congratulations but I'm I'm with it
because it's messy and me mean dirt like
messy all right so dirt can yeah they
compete with start let's say they do
Spider-Man comes out the same day it
will even go the same day not even
September the same day because Starfield
compete
yeah um hey hopeful quiz oh you're fine
I I'm kind of put in the chat guys I'm
kind of curious how you guys feel put it
in the chat do you think that Spider-Man
could compete with Starfield
okay let me tell you what I think
I think Spider-Man is going to be
massive of course man um Spider-Man is
going to be huge
but I think we need to sit back and
realize
um what a brand new IP from Bethesda
means
we talked about how Fallout 4 sold 12
million in what 24 hours
um what I'm saying is that
Spider-Man and two is going to be huge
don't get me wrong but it's only on
PlayStation
five at the moment
Starfield is going to be on PC and Xbox
I I can't see
um I I could be wrong obviously but I
can't see Spider-Man out shining if they
dropped on the same day of course
Spider-Man is gonna be huge I need
people to hear what I'm saying it's
going to be huge
but a brand new IP from Bethesda
like I mentioned where you hear their
last big game Fallout 4 sold 12 million
in 24 hours
that should let you know how big this
game is going to be
so yeah look that's all I got to say I'm
not even I I I'm not even gonna say that
star uh Spider-Man couldn't compare uh
compete with Starfield
but part of me feels like it would be
hard for it now Spider-Man is a huge
brand and that's why that's why I do
feel like there is going to be a point
where it can compete because of how big
it is but
what are we talking about the uh the
competition here cells
you know Spider-Man definitely could
compete with that Metacritic Spider-Man
definitely could compete with that but
if it comes down to like addressing the
hardcore like all right I want you guys
to put in the chat it's Starfield and
Spider-Man came out the same day what
are you playing first and I think that's
the biggest thing because you can win in
sales and you can win in in Metacritic
but if someone's playing something else
over the other that's where I think I
don't know I don't know what's gonna
happen with that
well
I think he was right like what are we
talking about sales are we talking about
streaming numbers are we talking about
what uh trending on Twitter what are we
talking about because
if it's Metacritic score I I believe
Spider-Man could beat Starfield in
Metacritic score I mean but when we're
talking about
what star field is going to be
the comp the conversation about Scott
Starfield is going to be huge and like I
said there's
PCS this game is going to be huge on PC
but that's the games usually always are
huge on PC even though it like Starfield
is going to be in Game Pass the game is
still going to be huge I believe not too
long ago they said it's still
um like on everybody's wish list on
Steam right now or something like that I
read not too long ago so I just believe
um because Spider-Man 2 is only on
Playstation yeah that's gonna hurt not
even on Playstation 4. it's only on
Playstation 5. I can totally see
um Starfield getting the shine a little
bit more but that's not like this is a
hypothetical conversation that's if they
drop it the same day it's not that I'm
underestimating Starfield I'm giving
Starfield its flowers I think some of
you in the chat are underestimating
Spider-Man
because even though that you know you
guys specifically might be playing that
there's going to be huge demographic of
people that know what Spider-Man is over
Starfield I don't know if they'll buy
the game
but you do have to look at that and plus
you know I would say that the MCU hype
train has kind of went down a little bit
so you know maybe that will result in
Spider-Man not selling as much as this
previous one because let's be real here
when Spider-Man came out in 2001 1918
18. 18 you know that I think that's when
the original when did The Originals the
new the newest Spider-Man start
relaunching it was around that time yeah
so it was 18.
watch to see man like I I just guys
don't don't underestimate Spider-Man to
that degree well I'm not saying that
they couldn't that there's no way
Starfield could do it but I'm saying
that is actually a legit Battle Star
Phil now if it was God of War versus
Starfield I'm saying Starfield is
completely destroying God of War but we
the Spider-Man goes beyond gaming and
that's the only wild card that I can
give it five dollars here from Cobb
weave come on people with Spider-Man for
uh we'll play Spider-Man for a weekend
nobody will care about the end of the
month Starfield will dominate the
conversation and twitch stop this
I do agree that Starfield will have a
longer effect you know um as far as like
the longevity has to say afterwards
absolutely
and that's my only thing is you know I
would say back then we were we were
gearing up to the infinity War we are
gearing up we were deep into you know
talking about gaming uh uh the MCU in
general
but I would say that the conversation
about the MCU isn't what it once was
that's not bad but it isn't what it once
was so I'm kind of curious on right now
what would Starfield do I mean uh
Spider-Man do I still think it's gonna
do numbers absolutely Spiderman yeah
yeah without that that MCU hype 24 7
that the MCU still has hype but not what
it once was
is a lot of the casuals going to Spring
out and buy it I don't know well you
know what I would say I would still say
yes because if you look at the MCU
lately
the only good movies are still like
the best MCU movie I've seen in the last
two years was Spider-Man no way home oh
that was still the past one I've seen so
Spiderman is still that character that's
going to do well but at the end of the
day I'm not just saying this as an Xbox
guy I I just really feel that Starfield
now Spider-Man could outselling I mean
no doubt about it but I just think like
the longevity
um maybe the twist numbers because
Spider-Man I mean I'm sorry because but
but there's the games are huge on PC
absolutely massive on PC and I just
really feel that Starfield is a game
that a lot of people have been waiting
for um including a lot of PC guys new IP
from Bethesda first one in years it's
gonna be huge but like Spider-Man's
gonna be huge too but I I don't know man
uh we got a five dollar subscribe from
uh boss Red Seven uh seven seven but
does them makes games that Define a
generation Sonic makes games that are
good for a few weeks again one ten years
other 10 uh 10 weeks at most I I feel
you on that but we're assuming
starfield's a hit too I mean look
there's a good chance Starfall comes out
and does what it's supposed to but
there's also a chance it doesn't by any
means uh you know I'm not trying to say
that it's going to be definitely you
know flopping or anything like that all
I would say is this is a newer type of
thing for them and you know sometimes
people drop the ball and stuff like that
now I will say I'm more confident in
Starfield because of the confidence that
Microsoft has had by letting them delay
it this many times I will say that so
when you look at that kind of
perspective they see very confident in
Starfield
extremely confident in Starfield
yep I agree it's a it's a big game man I
mean I don't know how many times we can
say this
it's a huge game
um it's one of the biggest games this
year
you know like next to you know zelding
tears of the frame rate
um you know that's a that's a big game
also oh but y'all the talk is in the
chat too
I mean somebody on my podcast um in the
chat said that I thought was hilarious
um no but it's it's gonna be fine man
you know it's gonna be fun
yeah so you know that that's pretty much
all uh when it comes to that I I will
say that you know I'll end it with I
would give this joking down it's like
I'm just joking man just joking I will
give it like a 50 50. if I would say
because the thing is is as much as I
have confident in Starfield
that Spider-Man man sometimes that that
would be going out like above and beyond
and you wouldn't even know uh
I see people in the chat I met people
couple people made a comment uh the
gameplay in the background of us is uh
lubu killing me for like an hour and a
half so
uh let me see so we're going on to the
next one at 24 minutes and 40 seconds
now we can finally get to uh wulong
Fallen Dynasty
and
I'm playing this game because I I did
review it so you can go on the channel
and look at it there
I'm looking at this game and I'm like
Microsoft needs to get more games like
this on Game Pass
um you know I'm not saying that
Microsoft doesn't have a good eye for
talent when it comes to stuff but I will
say that they need to be better on
getting some of the these games that I
feel is going to do really good now they
have gotten some good you know
quote-unquote bangers on Game Pass but I
feel like in a while this is the first
one that resonated with me
um
now have you played wulong yes I have um
and let me say this first I'm not a fan
of the styling games you know the from
software you know
but I gotta admit I'm actually enjoying
I'm not far I'm still on the first boss
I beat his first uh uh uh it was called
his first phase or whatever you call it
but but the second one kind of whooped
my ass so I gotta kind of go back and
you know I haven't played it in a couple
days but I actually like it and I do
think it's a great game for Game Pass
because I don't think I would have
bought it
because I'm not a fan of those style of
games but since it was in Game Pass I
downloaded it and it's a pretty quality
game man
yeah see what's funny is if you look in
the back because I moved our screens a
little bit lubu's just tearing me up man
I fought this dude for an entire day
dirt wow an entire day and did you beat
him eventually I beat the game but okay
uh two dollars super trap from Z Black
Rider uh ffs addicts grow up superheroes
are for Nintendo you look what they
telling us man
five dollar super trap from uh uh kubini
gaming King thrash already analyzed
Starfield saying the missing animations
Etc et cetera from the TV in the
background and that is not on Game Pass
um
yeah I don't know why
hold up
how do you
analyze something
that released how long ago
listen man I just I I'll just move on
brother just just move on trust me two
dollar Super Chat from clutchman01 I'll
be playing Starfield 10 years after
Spider-Man
I mean that that that's that's pretty
fair because uh people are still playing
um
Skyrim
that yeah to this day
bro not too long ago uh someone on my
podcast looked it up Skyrim was still
like
number 58 best selling games or
something like that on Steam bro like
really
still in the top 100 after all these
years
so let's be honest that's that's
um Spider-Man will probably is is listen
there's no probably to it it's going to
do well of course it's going to do well
no doubt about it but me personally I'm
I'm you know like I just finished Miles
Morales uh a few weeks ago you know it
was a good game Spider-Man
um Starfield is going to be a huge
massive game hours and hours and hours
of gameplay so
yeah I think I think people are going to
enjoy it not like when it comes to
you know woo long and Game Pass I think
it's a very good value to Game Pass it
shows that you know they they are
seeking because this is team ninja this
isn't some small example this is team
ninja and
um you know I think I think I think we
can look at that dirt
I'm gonna go out I'm gonna go out and
say I think Microsoft needs to be but
looking at Team Ninja for an acquisition
like I think that
Microsoft keeps missing that Souls vein
type of exclusive gameplay
I think at any time
and I'm not saying it could happen but
it's possible anytime we can wake up to
uh to Sony buying from software
yeah so to me with Sony having that
really close relationship with them
and the fact that they're either getting
timed exclusives or full-blown
exclusives on their games
Microsoft needs to do something else to
combat in that vein because I agree this
this scene isn't small anymore the seed
is a lot bigger Elder and raining
brought the from software's type of game
to a completely different level
uh okay we've got a five dollars Randy G
uh Marlin gaming was on was on a rant on
how bad Starfield looks I asked him if
it gets better uh meta than God of War
and he said Metacritic doesn't matter
hey man you know like sometimes you know
when I'm on the show The Box coming you
know they they be they'd be talking that
you know that blank
slow mo said uh that from Swatch is
owned by another company yeah and I I'm
not saying that you know I'm saying that
there's multiple ways that they can buy
that you know if they bought the company
that it belongs to if they if the
company sold it to them don't think any
company isn't worthy if so if someone
offered Microsoft enough money they'd
sell the Xbox brand to someone sure it'd
probably be at the abstronical an absurd
amount of money
but don't think money can change
conversations two dollars from Kyle weeb
uh for Microsoft to fund their own from
exclusive that's what I'm saying okay
okay dirt
tell me
to
tell me if I'm bucking
I think that Microsoft needs to reach
out to um
the people who own Ninja Gaiden I think
it's the
um
the people who publish this game not
trying to butcher their name you guys
I think they own uh Ninja Gaiden I might
be wrong I think you're right so
they need to reach out to them
and be like look we're gonna buy team
ninja we've already have the deal in
place
we want to license out or buy the Ninja
Gaiden franchise
and we want team ninja to make the game
and give them a good budget good
marketing budget games game does very
well
okay because to me you know team ninja
has always been in that
they're a couple off from having from
software type of uh you know product
and I think you know this game woo long
is it up there with the Eldon rings and
the second Rose but I would say this is
good as the majority of the Dark Soul
games
and to me they finally got into this
this realm where they can start doing
decent with this and
I'm not saying the Neo games were bad
I'm just saying woo long it is Neo
better
so that's why I'm feeling like you know
uh Ninja Gaiden that that's what I meant
Ninja Gaiden uh is what I meant
um so I'm thinking you you go out to
them getting into Gaiden have them
breathe life into that franchise and
imagine that showed up at a an E3
conference and it was an XBox exclusive
that's pretty good because wasn't there
a few of those games exclusive to the
original Xbox
yeah I think some of them were and that
that's what I think because Ninja Gaiden
already has like a little bit of Xbox
Brandy subconsciously on yeah yeah so
because I remember when there's a guy in
Black that was XBox exclusive or unless
I'm mistaken
yeah I think almost yeah did I remember
ninja guy and two was on a 360. I'm not
sure if that was exclusive hey Chad help
me out if I'm wrong
I thought another guy in two was
exclusive on the 360. I don't know
someone says I want them to buy Warner
Brother I I think their days of buying
Publishers are over yeah after this I
ain't seen them buying anymore they
might buy a small publisher but they
will never buy another publisher to this
degree again I can see them buying
Studios still but not Publishers bro I
can see them buying a small one that's
in like Japan maybe like a Sega or
something because they only got like
three or four Studios and I I don't
think I don't think that they would
they would cause this this much Ruckus
you know what I'm saying uh but as far
as like if you guys think they're going
to go out and buy like an EA or you'll
be a Ubisoft you know yeah that's done
yeah that is that is done done it's not
happening yeah
all right so those guys are saying those
games were exclusive yeah I thought they
were um so like you said they already
kind of had a relationship with Xbox in
the past
I agree with you uh haven't seen those
games used to be Niche like you said
used to be niche but Elder green proved
that they're not Niche anymore
and that that would be great to have uh
in-house XBox exclusive
um Dev team that's making those types of
games
quality also
yeah because quality matters
all right so let's uh let's move on man
you know we getting straight through
this let's let's let's let's be a little
messy Dart this is a little bit just a
little bit we're 34 minutes for the time
stat Mafia let's talk about PlayStation
being looks like petrified scared if
Microsoft buying this this this
Activision deal did you see that they
said that they're kind of concerned that
they would make
worse versions of the PlayStation yes
how did you feel when you saw this
um
honesty yeah the guys felt like they're
they're acting like some crybabies man
they're really acting really really
whiny right now
I understand that
they don't want Xbox to compete as a
like from a business standpoint but
they're looking real soft right now man
I I think they don't mind Xbox competing
but they want Xbox to compete on their
terms
right you know they don't want Microsoft
to buying these kind and you know if you
think about it
Nothing Like Mike nothing that Microsoft
is doing now it's it's never been done
in the industry like the status quo has
been where it is for years like years
it's been where it is
so to me
it would make sense why they're
uncomfortable with this and they didn't
Microsoft didn't go
for like the second hand thing they went
for the Divine Call of Duty because even
though King loves to uh you know get
messy with the with the console or stuff
a little bit on IOP he brought all the
PlayStation exclusives the hard copies
that he owned I saw that and he said all
of these games don't equal to this and
you know even though he was joking
he's right he's absolutely right because
if if Sony was if Sony had a hundred
percent confidence in the games that
they made they wouldn't care to lose
Call of Duty but the problem is is Call
of Duty makes them so much money it's
probably one of those things that they
use that to fund those other games well
they admitted that yeah
so yeah
it's well like first that was hilarious
what king Dave did but like you said it
was like like people were laughing but
at the end of the day Sony admitted that
that's the case
pretty much they said they use um Call
of Duty earnings to fund their first
party
yes I'm sorry go ahead yeah I was gonna
say I think people need to like
stop
assuming that this is coming look I I
see people and I know you've seen it
they're like oh but addicts you know
this is consolidation the industry has
been Consolidated for years like even
though there's Indie developers around
there's not many people actually doing
the kind of games of the majority of you
like there's like four big Publishers
that's all
and and I would be against the
Activision deal if I felt like they
could maintain that company better than
someone else do I is Microsoft gonna
come out there and do something better I
don't know
but we've seen
how Activision's handling it we've seen
how uh how how Blizzard's handling it
it's clearly not going the way that they
envisioned and as much as
it kind of you know
nervousing to see this consolidation to
this degree because at the end of the
day Activision is still a big entity
going into another big entity but
what's the alternative
we're going to keep getting
the type of Call of Duties every year
even though they're selling well
doesn't mean that the quality is not
going down
there's plenty of games with the quality
drastically go down and I see people
buying every year
man Madden I know a lot of people think
that about 2k uh so to me
if blizzard in an Activision have a
better shot at making more original IPS
have a better shot at being you know we
got to look at the aspect of how
everyone's being treated at Activision a
blizzard if you can improve that as well
then at this point what's what's the
harm
um
I agree man I agree uh
like you said activism blizzard was
having issues
um
they were having issues you know as far
as their CEOs you know accused of
certain things
there's some other people accused on
some stuff and at the end of the day man
um
I believe them being under Xbox
is something that
both sides want Xbox One and Activision
Blizzard wants this they said
everybody I believe Jazz Corden said
everybody he talked to at Activision
Blizzard said they want the acquisition
to go through because it benefits them
and to be under a a company like
Microsoft I mean that's a good thing man
I mean Microsoft is a huge company
um I know they've had layoffs recently
but they still are a very huge company
um one of the richest companies in the
world so you will want to be there if
you can
and you know that's how I feel about it
man because a lot of people
they they don't want it to happen you
know all over console war stuff
PlayStation just don't want it to happen
but you know I I get it from a
competition standpoint but like my boy
other zinc said you know it's business
but sometimes things can be bad business
and some some of the things the
PlayStation doing make you think like
damn
all right so slimy you know let's talk
about this because it kind of goes hand
in hand with what we're talking about
tell me you've seen that it's looking
like Microsoft might get the the sleazy
little hands
they they tricky little hands on those
marketing deals that PlayStation's been
doing since 2019. I love it
listen man you can't go to the like come
to the table and say yo this is going to
happen if they're allowed to acquire
this and this is wrong they're going to
do this they're going to make the
versions worse they're gonna
like you're saying all of this stuff I
just must say okay
why don't you go ahead and show The
Regulators what you guys have been doing
for years they tried to go all the way
back to 2012.
they wouldn't let them go back to 2012
so they said okay go to 2019. so if you
guys talking about Xbox is going to make
these games exclusive they're gonna do
this how about all of the games you took
off of Xbox I was by all of the games
because of your business practices
you made exclusive to PlayStation it's a
shame they couldn't get all the way to
2012. right it's the same we could have
got some juicy and some juicy stuff bro
but look you know at the end of the day
it's it's business but
if you guys are able to do business or I
can't Xbox do business right that's
that's how I feel about it I don't have
a problem with none of the time
exclusive deals Sony sign I don't have a
problem with that
but when you look at Microsoft let them
do business also
say uh if it's about competition let us
compete let's have competition right
listen if it's about competition let us
have competition and that's how I feel
about it man you can't let these guys do
it
but then when the other team tries to do
it you you try to stop them though
that's not fair but y'all are doing it
what why can't we do it so that's how I
feel about it man
do you think what kind of uh
what kind of things are you expecting
because I don't know if that's going to
be public or it's going to be leaked
I'm expecting a lot of things to be
redacted
um we might find out some some things
here and there but a lot of stuff might
be redacted now like we might see that
they're paying blocking rights for Game
Pass but we might not see how much or
what games you know what I'm saying so
stuff like I wonder it will be a lot I
wonder if the courts are still going to
see that or they're not going to see
that either
hmm so imagine like Microsoft getting
their hands on these deals in like half
of the the page is black
right like come on man with it uh I
would not put that pass on it it's like
that uh that thing for Friday where you
uh his mom gives him that bill and he's
like what is this
you expect me to do with this
this ain't enough
yeah that was listen that's definitely
possible at it like they could have
okay it's full of redacted stuff like oh
okay yeah that's possible man but the
course will see it though I believe
it's gonna be interesting man
let's be where we're going to see it you
know we might not see the the the court
findings but someone leaking that [__]
we gonna hit something
yo we gonna have one hell of an addict
show when that happens oh man
oh my God babe Saudi I I just
I don't I don't get how someone that
does
such slimy practices
always try to play the victim
like what's funny is like people sit
there and they'll say
addict what Microsoft is doing is wrong
they might rip off
uh you know Call of Duty in 10 years
then
first off people keep saying that 10
years thing and they're not looking at
Microsoft's giving you 10 plus years 10
years to come up with a alternative
and I don't even think then as long as
Call of Duty is still going strong which
it probably will be I don't even think
then they'll stop it
because that's a lot of money but you
know what it is there's a lot of other
stuff there is
you know the Crash Bandicoot franchise
that's in that deal uh the spiral
franchise that's in that deal you don't
think about blizzard you know yeah
blizzard they the king
you know OverWatch that that is a lot of
power for one company but like I said
the only difference between what
Microsoft and what Sony is doing is
money
um Sony's going out there and spinning
to me large amounts of money to make
games timed exclusives and then they pay
more money to extend the time
exclusivity
they're making it to where by the time
these games come out on the Microsoft
platform in the in the micros of the
Xbox ecosystem
it's irrelevant
no one cares anymore and I I think
that's the biggest issue people will
Overlook that I find it
hilarious
to look at something like Microsoft
doing something like this and they get
put put as the villain but Sony has made
it to where I can't get any Final
Fantasy game
but that that's okay
and I don't I don't I don't think that's
right right uh to me
what's the difference between Sony
locking down for spoken
Final Fantasy 16 Final Fantasy 7 Final
Fantasy VII part two other you know
yeah they have a couple other games
under their thing especially with Square
Enix like when we're not getting Square
Enix games generally besides Final
Fantasy uh Crisis Core
they're doing the same thing just in a
different way
at least Microsoft is coming up to
Activision and say yo we believe in this
company enough where we're just gonna
buy it
your problems are going to be our
problems
but active uh but Sony is just locking
all the titles down and you know I would
be very curious
very curious dirt if they had the same
topic the same energy if Microsoft but
Game Pass rights for like the next 10
years
[Laughter]
they will be pissed yeah
they'll be pissed about that
um like you said man it's just I
understand Call of Duty is a bigger deal
than those Square Enix games
but at the end of the day bro there's
people on Xbox that want to play those
games doing the 360 generation and the
and Final Fantasy 15 all of the Final
Fantasy games were on Xbox except for
what was that 14
um I believe yeah 13's when they started
coming over 13 is when they start right
okay
um but look man it's just kind of
like I said it's hypocritical when you
are doing something
and then when somebody else tries to do
something
and but it hurts you you're like no you
can't do that that's what pisses me off
man like I've always had respect for
PlayStation never too much like
PlayStation Fanboys but I always have
respect for PlayStation but some of that
respect is kind of dwindling like
come on man y'all y'all the Sony y'all
y'all are the market leader um y'all are
PlayStation man y'all have dominated
most of the generations like three of
the four three of the four generations
the past Generations y'all dominated man
like
I don't understand why there are really
just they're looking vulnerable to me
and
I know some guys will deny it but we see
what's going on like you just said they
acting like they they brand new in the
industry and what's crazy is the name
another one people doing this it's not
like
I would understand if Microsoft was
close on their Hills and I would
understand that they generally felt like
they couldn't compete that's the reason
they're doing this but I don't think
competition has anything to do with
their motives they don't want to lose
that Call of Duty money
on this and they feel like with Call of
Duty with a going into you know game
pass because if you've noticed they've
offered them 10 years that's not enough
they've offered them a variety of
different things the only thing that
Sony seems to be comfortable with is The
Game Pass not being a thing and I think
that's their motives they're trying to
get
some kind of deal made where Microsoft
can't put that in Game Pass
and Microsoft's okay
how about we offer it to you too but
right but the thing is PlayStation I
want to pay for that nope they don't so
they they really seem like that snobby
stuck up
spoiled rich kid that nothing's good
enough
hey Annie I don't know if you um saw
what Lulu hat said she quoted exactly
what Jim Ryan said
um this is what Lulu Chang um said on
Twitter because I know if you saw it but
I'll read it I was passed out until
about four yeah
now these are Jim Ryan words per Lulu
ching
I don't want a Call of Duty I don't want
a new Call of Duty deal I just want to
block you a merger
and Tom Warren asked her when did Jim
say that and she responded February 21st
she quoted Jim Ryan I don't want a new
Call of Duty deal I just want to block
you a merger
and you know be funny
if micros because they can't come to a
middle ground because it's it's clearing
like some of these countries are
coming around on what's gonna happen
with this you know it's just now it's
just the big ones uh you know the United
States you know we got a couple other
things and what's funny is I'm looking
at this and I'm like wouldn't it be
funny
if all of this Jim Ryan going through
all this trying to get this deal blocked
if he ended up
not only not getting the still blocked
but not making these deals with
Microsoft when it was when it was
strategically uh
strategically beneficial for Sony to
take these deals and Microsoft gets this
passive no cons uh no no restrictions
that would literally be the worst case
scenario for PlayStation and what can if
that happens what game day has been
saying for the longest about PlayStation
6. that will become a reality yeah
but at that point man I'm like
do it do it like because to me it's like
they didn't they didn't respect the the
deal so why should you respect them with
the outcome Yep they're they're trying
to stop the deal
wow that's that's incredible because of
a few people DM me that and I said wow
it'd be like one of those things okay
you know we we can't
we can't do nothing I'm kind of curious
how much PlayStation values the Call of
Duty brand right now so Microsoft don't
really have a lot of Leverage because
they're still trying to win the court
case to take the company but dirt
when if they win
Microsoft will have all of the leverage
to go into these meetings oh and they
think they think that the
the deals that was being made now are
unfair imagine when you start putting on
the case where it's oh yo
okay now we offered you 10 years we're
doing year to year
and you're getting 30 40 percent
oh but you know what well but but but
but Phil we we we normally do 30. now
it's 20. keep talking right
but what what what are we gonna do what
you got no it's what but what are we
gonna do with that what can you do is
the better question
Jim Ryan
because it's just like one of those
things where you know I don't if they're
Petty I don't blame them
because even like let's let's talk about
a a realm where this doesn't go through
let's talk about a realm where
Jim Ryan successfully blocks
Call of Duty and blocks this deal I I
find it hard to believe like I've said
this that that relationship's going to
be the same that relationship is over
absolutely bro because you're not
affecting
the people working for Activision you're
affecting the people funding Activision
and when you tell them you can't have
their stocks at a higher rate
they're going to be like no why are we
working with these people now do I think
they're going to pull Call of Duty all
over the place they know but don't I
wouldn't be surprised
if there's conversations going into
Activision right now where I don't care
if they will if they I don't care if
XBox loses this this deal they're not
getting the marketing rights uh the only
people getting that's Microsoft
absolutely I guarantee I I
wholeheartedly agree with you the
relationship can never be the same
because one until leadership changes
yeah yeah true but but I would say this
PlayStation mess with those Executives
money we all know Bobby code Tech and
Lou Lawton they're getting bonuses
especially Bobby he's getting a hell of
a bonus because that's probably the only
time he's ever going to be able to to
cash out yeah bro you're messing with
their money so now a lot like you said
they won't pull
um cars from PlayStation because it does
make money but the relationship can
never be the same like you said as soon
as 2024
they're going to get those marketing
rights to Xbox easy if the deal didn't
go through but of course we expect the
deal to go through but you're right man
that relationship can never be the same
don't mess with don't mess with that
money bro and y'all messing with their
money that's why Lulu's so pissed
because they want the deal to go through
yeah it's just
It's just sad man it's sad that you know
these companies uh you know
they're talking you know what you know
Jim Ryan we agree with you we agree we
think that Call of Duty needs to be
everywhere but we think Spider-Man needs
to be everywhere too right so you know
what if you truly feel that way we will
we won't even we won't even hide Call of
Duty from your guys's peoples but I I'm
gonna I'm gonna send this Dev kid over
there but you know what some of your
people already have our deaf kit you
know go over there to the people that
make the show tell them to send you our
deaf kit and I'm expect I may expect a
release date for Spider-Man in six
months on our platform
now be crazy man
yeah it's just it's it's it's funny it
really is and I hope things work out for
the best but part of me thinks this is
going to get worse before it gets better
especially when these marketing deals
leak
oh
yeah that's gonna be interesting man all
this stuff coming out is gonna be very
interesting bro yeah and for years
people have told me that Sony isn't
doing stuff like that for years people
have told me that Sony doesn't need to
do stuff like that that they don't need
to lock timed exclusives that they don't
need to talk to Square Enix about making
sure games don't come to Xbox people
like oh but there's games go Nintendo
yeah but no games go on Xbox
look at it from the perspective of Ori
in the blind Forest those games were
everywhere but at PlayStation
hmm
and I think that PlayStation and Xbox
they're willing to work with Nintendo
because they don't see them as a
competition in the same vein right both
companies have worked with Nintendo
I mean how we just had them working out
a deal with GoldenEye
so there is things like that going on uh
but you know it is what it is
let's let's do it man let's get to the
main event of the evening let's go man
we are 57 minutes uh not 47 I'll have
the people at me if I put 47.
57 minutes
so let me tell you how my God how my
morning's like last night I spent the
majority of the time
you know what's funny is I left my
window open all night all all morning
so my room was cold when I was yeah yeah
I see you bundled up man yeah so let me
tell you guys I I stayed up all a good
amount of last night like looking over
PAX East emails and stuff
so
I'm looking at all this going down
and
I go to sleep
wake up
I knew something was up
because I had 20 plus notifications on
Twitter
and
the IOP chat was crazy it had like 30
missed messages
so I'm like oh oh god what happened so I
get on there I see
something I didn't expect
which is a release date for Starfield
I kind of figured they wouldn't do that
to the event
but they they surprised me with the
whole thing
so it looks like starfield's coming out
September what 16th sixth sixth
September the 6th
um
it kind of makes me wonder where they're
going to put Forza
at that point I don't know
maybe that's coming out in July junish
possibly so starfield's coming out
September the 6th uh we got a two dollar
scripture from rain G4 where PS5 get
star fifth wall pay
yo let's what's that thing called um
that animation their background stuff
uh
uh the dynamic background yeah let's get
a dynamic start well I mean the PS5
don't can't do that in the background I
know the PS4 could I don't know why they
stopped that
oh let PS4 get it then that would even
be worse PS4 can get you know what let
them have a a PS4 runs worse starfish
no I'm joking all right so because then
that would just make Starfield look bad
all right so it's coming out September
6th uh clearly it has went past that 12
months
so what what do you think is going on
here man like first off the first thing
I want us to talk about is just your
overall perspective of this game missing
that 12 months I don't really want to go
in like this September speculation yet
just this game missing that's six months
okay
um but I'll say this
um I would say this uh we know delays
happen
but also in the future they should be
hesitant to do that 12-month thing again
just my opinion
um because you know if you're not going
to be able to 100 keep it
keep the dates I mean the games within
12 months you know you shouldn't Rook do
it real quick you know you know what I'm
starting to think they did that 12 month
thing what's that because of this Call
of Duty thing
you think so because now I was thinking
about it it because look at Sony Sony
even do a show last year right and I
think this Call of Duty thing has a lot
to do with that too and you know
obviously both of these companies are
low-key trying to look you know
more weak than the other
and what what's going to be looking bad
for Microsoft is does it come out
showing these unannounced games and you
know what these games are going to look
like so I think that might be one of the
reasons that they avoided that 12 months
so I don't know if that will I don't
know if that was ever going to like
repeat you know what I'm saying well you
know what you say that but I had
mentioned this before I always felt that
they didn't well they did the 12 month
thing because they already have so many
announce games that's far out and I
didn't think they wanted to add to that
far out list with some more new games
that's going to be far out where they
don't really have any release dates for
some some of the games that's already
announced
um so we can both be right actually
um
but as far as Starfield listen man
honestly I'm going to be absolutely 100
honest
They delayed it three months
make sure the game is as good as it can
be and I'll be happy about that but just
the 12 month thing I you know I expect
the PlayStation Fanboys to make fun and
laugh about that
um but some of the XBox guys they're
kind of upset about it you know okay I
get it
um I do think the 12 month thing they
need to be very careful with that uh I
don't think they should do that again
because things like this can happen
right and we don't want this to happen
again next year but honestly bro three
months
I'm cool with it man I believe this will
make the game even better
and that's just how I feel about it um
let me get the super chat from Michael G
speaking of Dev kits when Microsoft has
Call of Duty this would mean PlayStation
would have to say Microsoft a deaf kit
of PlayStation 6. yeah I mean but also
vice versa because you know they got the
show Minecraft yeah Minecraft so I mean
I think they both know each other
you know power or whatever was going on
because you know people always leave one
Studio go to another Studio they have
they know all that stuff
um there's another Super Chat from bone
slave
time to get rid of the 12 month BS they
already messed that up with their
biggest IP of the Gin aside from Halo
yeah yeah listen I didn't like the 12
month thing from the beginning I didn't
either but I was I was hey I was rocking
with it but now since this happened I
don't think they should do it again but
as far as the game being delayed it
doesn't bother me at all I do think the
12 month thing can work as long as
they stick with it like this year if
they did the 12 month thing again you'd
you'd be seeing hellblade a vowed uh you
know whatever compulsion games working
almost likely you'd be seeing some of
their uh you know Indie stuff that they
do you'd be seeing some Game Pass stuff
as long as they consistently show the
output maybe Indiana Jones I could see
why you could keep that 12 month up and
then next year you know you don't really
show too much in terms of gameplay you
show a little bit just not a lot then
they do another direct at the beginning
of next year and show those gains in
more detail but I think we can all agree
here that we want to see what we're
looking forward to we don't want to see
stuff in the past we don't want to see
stuff we've already that's already been
announced we want E3 to be showing us
why we should invest into the into the
brand
past this year
I agree like you said live the little uh
developer directs that can be for the
announced games but E3 we want to see
see some new stuff
um TX TX
t-h-x1138 with the two Starfield release
date
take two
yeah let's hope that that don't they
don't get messed up again
yeah so what
what's your expectations of star Phil I
think it's going to be a massive game
man I think it'll be one of them games
you just play for a long time
um I think they're taking their time
with this game man they're trying to
make it as good as it can be I think
it's gonna be huge man things will be
huge
um
I'm going to take my time with the game
I'm not going to rush through it I'm
going to take my time with them and it's
one of them games you're just gonna
you know just put plenty of out like
hundreds of hours into it and I can't
wait man
um hold up we're gonna talk about
redfall 2 because I I've seen
doing some giant red fall stuff I'm sure
you've seen that people going out to
redfall
so we'll talk about that briefly after
this uh I actually have a lot of faith
in Starfield it's uh it's
people don't know this but I'm a huge uh
huge like obsidian fan of a huge when it
comes to you know Fallout fan I'm a huge
the majority of these games like I love
them man I I remember Fallout 3 playing
that I remember playing Fallout New
Vegas to a huge round I know that was
made by obsidian but still I remember
taking turns with my cousin switching
back from Morrowind to RuneScape when I
used to play that on PC
I played a lot of these games like a
ridiculous amount like kind of too much
and that's why I'm sitting over here
like
I want this game to be good and I know
that the 12 months thing is slightly
annoying that you couldn't make that 12
months but you know what's more annoying
dirt start for coming out not working
right if they need that three months to
make sure that that game comes out and
hits the way it's supposed to
give them that three months absolutely
no question about it I can't
realistically
be up here telling you guys that I'm
tired of broken games I'm tired of the
games not functioning correctly and I'm
tired of all that
but then I come and tell you rush games
to get them out
look if you need the time give them the
time because I think
a game that was delayed that ends up
being good is better than a game that
comes out buggy and everyone remembers
that you know there's so many games now
that are good games even something like
cyberpunk
got a huge turnaround no one cares
because when it mattered the game come
out broken
and to me
how could we expect them to get rid of
the term bug Festa when we don't care if
they need more time
right in the grand scheme thing what is
three months
it was three months bro we've waited
this long what's another three months
nothing
an attic and I always say when the game
is delayed right and then when it
releases and it's polished and it's a
good game
nobody talks about the delay anymore no
one
as long as the game is good now don't be
a Saints Row get delayed and still come
out cheeks that's something different
but if the game is delayed and drops
great nobody talks about that delay
unless they talk about it in a positive
way like yo that delay was needed is
great now
it's just one of those things where
we need this to work out uh you know
Microsoft really needs this they they
the only time that I would have
personally got annoyed the only time I
personally would have got annoyed is
if they
delayed it
and talked about it again at E3
or their E3 conference it does look like
that
that star Phil conference is going to be
around that time frame but it's not
going to be in it in yeah not it will
probably be our own event yes and I'm
okay with that because that was my
biggest fear it's like if you're saying
12 months if you have to delay a game
out of that 12 months I guess but don't
show that damn game again right you know
especially if they do the 12 month thing
again how bad is that going to look
they're doing a 12 months
the same game that was supposed to be
out the last time they said it was going
to be on 12. that will now be a good
look yeah so like don't show that again
all right go ahead and keep that let it
have its own event
and then we will go from that game
to the event or the event to that game I
think it'll probably be in that week uh
one thing I'm interested is
I'm going to be in E3 this year so I'm
kind of curious since that's pushed in
September how much access I can get to
it before September
because I'm excited about Starfield I
think it's going to be a fantastic game
I think you guys gonna enjoy it I really
do
um I hope
God God forbid this game doesn't come
out doesn't hit what it's supposed to
yeah oh my God man that's gonna be
horrible I think it will though I think
it will I think uh Microsoft and
Bethesda knows how important this game
is for Xbox
and they're gonna do it right man I
really feel that way let me get a super
chat for you bone slave with the tool
Starfield has to hit after these delays
thank you bone slave appreciate you bro
yeah I I think it's gonna hit let's talk
about redfall real quick
um looking forward to it I have been
seeing a lot of
a lot of uh you know content creators
being uh flown out and stuff to look
like la
and you know they're getting hands on
with redfall now they haven't said they
haven't shown because obviously if
you're flowing influence and stuff out
there they're covering it clearly uh so
the fact that I haven't seen any
coverage yet because I was like two days
ago
I'm assuming there is uh obviously an
NDA on it absolutely so I would expect
here in the next couple weeks we're
gonna get like a giant drop of redfall
coverage yep I think so too
and uh
I'm still indifferent about red fault I
think I think it's it's similar to what
I had when it came to
when it came to um
what's that game the one though that uh
death Loop
I want a Dishonored I don't want a
redfall I love the universe they built
and Dishonored and I think I'm looking
at redfall and that's that's kind of
clouding my judgment really because it's
like one of those things where you see
your favorite Studio make a game that
you love but they're not making that
game that you love right
that's where I'm at currently you know
I'm not saying rifle ain't gonna be good
I think
arcane's a very talented studio and I
think they're gonna hit
but
I would be
I would be lying if I say I wasn't
worried for
the enjoyment I will have with it now I
hopefully I'll be reviewing it and you
know if I review it you guys you guys
know how it is
I tell you the truth if it's bad it's
bad it's good it's good
and I'm curious to see how it hits I'm
curious to see how some of these aspects
work I I do see a lot of things that
that redfall is doing really interests
me and and it gauges uh my interest but
I still look at the game and I'm just
like why are they making something like
this like I'm not used to and that might
be it too because I'm not used to that
this type of game from them
so you know I feel I feel it on that
Donald tux's attic been skeptical about
every game this generation I literally
was just giving Starfield praise we're
gonna we're gonna move past that so what
what do you feel dirt what's going on
with you well I I I I disagree with you
um but I understand where you're coming
from
I just think that sometimes you have to
take a gamble on something
um
realistically if you think about it the
the mindset that I have where I want
Dishonored from them uh fortnite never
would have came been a thing because
then they would have just went and
worked on something like yours
so you know they never would have made
four epic yeah epic okay yeah you gotta
see you got to gamble on something to
see because prey was a great game but it
didn't move units Dishonored 2 was a
great game it didn't move units part
part one so well but for some reason
part two didn't move units so
I don't think death Loop um
was super successful either
um so redfall is a game I believe that
you know Arcane and say you know what
listen guys let's try a little Co-op
let's try vampires let's try a little
small town or let's try something
different and I'm 100 fine with that the
the aspects and the direction they're
taking the vampire thing it is it is
looking cool you know I'm not gonna say
it's not oh what we're gonna see because
I have a feeling in the next couple
weeks we're we're gonna we're gonna see
stuff we're gonna see some drastic uh
gameplay with red fire I have a feeling
a lot of previews yeah people like me
that wanted more coverage on redfall we
about to get that in huge waves
I'm super high for rarefall man um like
you said I see somebody in the chat uh
bone slaves that Dishonored 2 was fire
yes it was it was a great game man like
I said I even love the little DLC
um but redfall looks incredible to me
I loved that flute but it took me a
while to get death Loop I don't think
redfall is going to be like the same
it's it like it seems to be a game you
can get into quicker
um so yeah I'm looking forward to real
far man I love how the town look I love
I don't know it's something about me
with games I love to be in like regular
towns you know like like sometimes I
don't like fantasy stuff sometimes
sometimes I like to be
in a town you know I'm saying like Alan
Wake you know Quantum break stuff like
that I don't know that's just me uh but
you're in the town and I like it man it
looks great to me
yeah I think I will probably be talking
about this here in the next couple weeks
um
it's it's it didn't happen today
so I would assume it will happen next
week or maybe the week after because
sometimes with these type of uh these
type of things they have multiple layers
of it you know what I'm saying can I say
something to somebody in the chat record
sure
hey Frank Kenton said redfall won't sell
Xboxes nobody said it would
nobody said it would not there's only
certain games that will sell the console
and most of those games are usually
multiplies by the way yeah and I guess
we can start naming games that didn't
sell PlayStations Valkyrie Elysium
didn't sell PlayStations I can assure
you that but people like the game
um what was that um
that Predator game that didn't sell a
part of the hunting grounds PlayStation
there's a lot of games that don't
forespoke and definitely did some places
that didn't sell any PlayStations look
man sometimes okay like if you're a NBA
team
if you have a solid team you have a good
team maybe not a huge Superstar
being a good team will sell tickets
right
being a good team will sell tickets but
then you have a team that has a
superstar
that guy sales tickets and people come
to see that guy so you can do both
if you have a strong portfolio you have
a strong lineup of games have a strong
service you have a good console and a
good ecosystem
maybe it's not about selling consoles
like it used to be right just by getting
into the ecosystem and then on on the
PlayStation side they have a Spider-Man
that's gonna that can sell
PlayStations absolutely is going to sell
PlayStations but then again again my
Call of Duty
sales PlayStations right
so come on man everything is not going
to sell everything come on man you just
being petty at this point
yeah I hear you but I think we're gonna
go ahead and uh
close this down
um all right so what what is what what
can the people find yet man because you
know I think I think in the next couple
weeks going to be interesting I'm very
interested to see it you guys know how I
do these shows I'll try to keep uh dirt
here hostage for too too long
uh so what where can the people find you
at man
well check out my channel I dropped a
video earlier about uh Starfield I have
another video I'm going to upload this
so definitely it's definitely a console
war video I'm making fun of this
PlayStation fan boy it's acting like
he's a um he's The Insider saying
PlayStations buying take two I'm about
to drop that one in a few
you know I have a little fun
so yeah I'm putting my um link on my
channel in the chat
for the Bots that want to follow a bot
have a good good old time
thank you
appreciate it yeah and
um definitely follow me on Twitter Lord
addict IOP
I'm going to be going over a lot of pax
e stuff I might actually do like a live
stream just going over the Pax East
games uh showing you guys what you know
I'm going to be covering there myself
then probably afterwards I'll give you
the addicts choice or iops uh like proof
of uh iron cell well however we
pronounce it these days I don't know but
I'm pretty sure for coming through man
we add up to 420 people and you hit that
like button on your way out and I'm
gonna hold your shoes Ransom until you
hit that like button
you know you ain't gonna get those back
you gonna don't walk out of the house
barefooted I know that's very
uncomfortable don't do that okay so just
hit that like button and I give you your
boots out the door
but until you hit that like button they
my boots and I'm size 15. I guarantee
you I don't fit the majority of your
guys's shoes you wear 15. yes I do
look
my shoes are huge dude
damn bro
how tall are you six six four oh damn
see I'm six three but I wear 13. so I
got a little small punks for you after
10. yeah that's what I'm saying man size
15. your shoes don't fit me
but I get I'm sure Salvation Army can
use some uh smaller shoes so don't play
with me don't play with me it's an attic
is a shooting guard that's probably
that's why the height of a shooting
guard is six four it's the point guard
oh my God but I'll talk to you guys
later man you guys have a good day I'm
sure Dirk got some stuff he gotta do I
gotta actually wake up and eat
yeah get you something to eat uh but I
appreciate everyone coming through here
until next week this is addict and dirt